Evet pratik Çok teşekkür ederim davet
ettiğiniz için açıkçası girişimcilik
yolunda tedex bence çok önemli bir
kaynaktır herkesin bol bol dinlemesini
öneriyorum Ben bugün size yeni nesil
girişimcilik ve milyar dolarlık şirket
kurma ile ilgili
bilinenlerin çok aksinde bir sunum
hazırlamak istiyorum şimdi yeni normalde
yani yeni dünyada Ne okudun nerede
okudun ne bildiğin kaç yaşında olduğunu
alanında ilk olup olmadığın çünkü bizde
şöyle var Aa yepyeni bir fikir buldum
kimsenin bilmediği kimsenin düşünmediği
açıkçası milyar dolarlık teknoloji
şirketi kurulmasında pek önemi olmadığı
ortaya çıktı ve biraz açıkçası değişik
kafaları yakan bir düşünce şimdi ne
okuduğuna bir gelelim Yani bugün silikon
vadisine baktığın zaman Funk şirketleri
var bir dedikleri işte Facebook Apple
Amazon netflix Google denen Bunların
çoğu üniversite diplomasının çok gerekli
olmadığını
düşünüyorlar Google üniversite
önemine inanmadığı gibi tamamen kaldırıp
kendi eğitim programı olan Google
kariyer programını başlatıyor Hatta
Google'ın işe alım kılavuzu vardır
officialing derler Google işe alım
kılavuzunda resmi işe alın rehberinde
yani üniversite kelimesi ve kolej
kelimesi de tamamen kaldırılmış
durumdadır Yani açıkçası teknoloji
işindeki insanların ya da teknolojik
kuracak teknolojik şirketi kuracak
insanların açıkçası pek ne okuduğunu bir
önemi kalmıyor Hatta önemi olmadığı
artık 30 yıllık veriyle sabitlenmiş
durumda ve çok ilginç bir şekilde
yazılımcıların %70'i kendi kendine
öğrenen insanlardır ve yazılımcıların
%56'sıda bu hacker rank raporunda çok
100 bin kişi üzerinde yapılmış bir
ankettir yazılımcıların yüzde 56'sının
da üniversitede promosyon yok Yani çoğu
insan kendi öğrenmiş ve kendi kendine
geliştirmiş insanlar olduğunu görüyoruz
ve teknoloji şirketi kurucuların da pek
çoğunun böyle olduğunu görüyoruz ve
ilginç bir şekilde Artık insanlar
akademik kaynaklar ya da üniversiteden
bir şey öğrenmektense YouTube'a daha çok
güveniyorlar online kaynaklara site
overflowdur yazılımcılar için teknoloji
insanları için işte hackerlar gibi
kaynakları daha çok güvenip inanmaya
başlıyorlar ve daha kolay
öğrenebildiğini düşünüyorlar peki
diğer alana geçelim ne öğrendiğinin ne
okuduğunu çok bir önemi yoksa nerede
olduğunun bir önemi var mı Yani illa
silikon vadisinde ne olacaksın İlla
Amerika'da mı olacaksın diye genelde bir
düşünce var açıkçası uzaktan çalışmaya
imkan sağlayan teknolojiler sayesinde
açıkçası her yerde başarılı
olabiliyorsunuz Ben kendimden örnek
vereyim Bir zürum de 40 kişilik bir
ekibimiz var 50'ye yakın investerımız
var Binlerce müşterimiz var biz bunların
hiçbiri ile yüz yüze gerçekte görüşmedik
tamamen Hepsini şu anda yaptığımız gibi
Zoom üzerinden yaptık ve tamamen Zoom
üzerinden
ilişkimizi de devam ediyor ve böyle
düşündüğünüz zamanında açıkçası bunu bu
haritada da görebiliyoruz yani milyar
dolar olmuş Yeni Kon şirketleri dünyanın
artık her tarafında çıkabiliyor bugün
estonya'dan Çin'e Hindistan'dan
Singapur'a Dünyanın her yerinde milyar
dolarlık değer oluşturmuş yaratmış
kazanan şirketleri olduğunu ve onlarca
şirketin genelde olduğunu görüyoruz Peki
çok ilginç diğer bir konu Yani ne
okuduğumun önemi çok yoksa nerede
olduğumu çok önemi yoksa ben o zaman çok
fazla tecrübe mi sahibi olmalıyım diye
bir düşünce oluyor genelde insanların
kafasını açıkçası milyar dolarlık şirket
kurmak için sektörde uzman
uzmanlık öyle düşünüldüğü kadar da
önemli bir şey değil hatta çok yeni bir
kitap çıktı Ali Temel yazdı bu bir ünlü
bir yatırımcı silikon vadisinde
kitabının adı da süper falandır bu
kitaptan birkaç şey paylaşacağım size
çok ilginç bir şekilde milyar dolarlık
şirket kurmuş insanların
yüzde ellisinden fazlasının bu alanda
hiçbir deneyimi yok yani
uber'ın kuran insan taksici değildir
Instagram'ı kuran insan fotoğrafçı
değildi netflix'i kuran
kişi
bir film yapımcısı film yönetmeni ya da
Hollywood içinden birisi değildi ya
tamamen Hatta hollywood'a Ters birisi
amazon'un kurucusu Jeff bozos bir
Dükkanı yoktu değil mi tamamen
e-ticarete geldi ve bunu da biz
artırabiliriz gidebilir ve bugün
görmüşler unicorn kurmuş milyar dolarlık
şirket kurmuş insanların genellikle
sektör bilgisi yok Hatta ben kendi
kendinden örnek verirsem ilk kurduğum
e-ticaret Sitesi cep telefonu satış
sitesiydi ikinci el cep telefonu daha
sonra çocuk cep telefonu yaptık Daha
sonra e-ticaret silikon vadisinde sosyal
network kurmuştuk film marketinki film
tanıtımları için sonra arttırılmış
gerçeklik ve remot para gönderme işi
yapıyoruz Ben bu işlere girerken bu
alanlarda hiçbir deneyimim yoktu ve
bunun da zaten böyle olduğunu görüyoruz
Peki diğer türlü yaş ve deneyim aynı şey
olmadığını görür Peki milyar dolarlık
şirket kurmuş İnsanların bu deneyimi
nasıl kazandığına baktığımız zaman
genellikle yaparak öğrenmiş insanlar
oluyor ve genelde bir iki Hatta üç
şirket kurmuş Kimisini batırmış ya da
kimisine exit etmiş daha sonra öyle
35'li yaşlarda geldiği zaman milyar
dolarlık şirket kurduğunu görüyoruz
açıkçası bir de şöyle bir düşünce var
hepimizin kafasında ya Ben pazarda ilk
olayım ilk düşüneyim Ben ilk defa
düşündüm bunu Aslında bunun da çok garip
bir şekilde yanlış olduğunu gördük Hatta
genelde unicorn olmuş milyar dolarlık
şirket olmuş firmalar pazara
girdiklerinde en az 5 bazı durumlarda da
ona yakın
rakibinin olduğunu görüyoruz hatta çok
komik bir şeydir bu çok ilginç Eski Bir
Hikaye Google'ın ana yatırımcısı çok
ünlü sekoya katıl diye bilinen pek çok
firmanın yatırımcısı olan bir firmadır
bir yatırım firmasıdır Ben Türker katıl
bunu da kurucusu dambılın Time diye bir
kişi bu kişi Google'a yatırım yaparken
şöyle bir laf ediyor Yani Google'a
yatırım yaptıkları sırada 180 tane arama
motoru varmış ve diyor ki bir
konuşmasında o gün Google'ın başarılı
olduğuna inanmak için gerçekten espri
anlayışınızın çok yüksek olması lazımdı
diyor çünkü 180 içinde sen başarılı
olduğuna inanmak gerçekten
bir değişik bir kafa yapısı lazım Ama o
firma başarılı oluyor işte Nasıl o fark
yaratıyor biraz Buna da gireceğiz şimdi
o zaman milyar dolarlık şirket ya da
başarılı teknoloji şirketi kurmak için
ne okuduğunun nerede olduğunu ne
bildiğinin kaç yaşında olduğunu ve
alanında ilk olup olmadığını neredeyse
önemi az denecek kadar
iyi bir şekilde az Peki o zaman bu
insanların ortak özelliklerine
baktığımız zaman ne görüyoruz genelde
ürün odaklı insanlar olduğunu görüyoruz
İnanılmaz bir şekilde ürüne
odaklanıyorlar ürünü en iyi şekilde
yapmaya çalışıyorlar bugün işte
ilanmazdı gördüğümüz gibi yani ilanmaz
her gün teslasını kullanıyor her gün
ürünle ilgili bir fikir verirken belki
Ford'un CEO'su hiçbir zaman arabasını
kullanmıyor ve hep ürün odaklılar ürünü
de insanlara gerçekten fayda sağlamak
için kendilerine fayda sağlamaktan
ziyade insanlara nasıl fayda
sağlayabilirim zamanlarını
kısaltabilirim buna odaklı oluyorlar ve
sorulduklarında amaçları hiçbir zaman
para kazanmak değil ve fırsatları en
önemli özellik Aslında şu; ve bunu biraz
daha derinleştireceğiz
fırsatları bir kere değil Sürekli gören
bir yapıları var Yani bu biraz sörf
yapmaya benziyor yani dalgayı bir kere
yakalayıp bir kere yapmaktansa sürekli
sürekli sürekli dalgalı dalgayı
yakalayan fırsatları yakalayan insanlar
olduğunu görüyoruz ve bunu da şöyle bir
özetleyelim yani teknoloji
girişimciliğini bir cümleyle
basitleştirip özetlersek girişimcilik
fırsatları görmektir fırsatları gören
insandır girişimci insan ve bunu da
değerli baktığımız zaman fırsatlar
zamana ve pazara bağlı
ol zaman ve pazar değiştikçe sürekli
değişir yani bugünkü bugün olan
fırsatlar çok farklıdır Yarın olan
fırsatlar çok farklıdır seneye olan
fırsatlar farklıdır ve her zaman bu
fırsatlar Çığ topu gibi artar kar topu
gibi artar artar artar Çünkü pazar
genişliği teknoloji gelişiyor daha çok
insanlar giriyor ve biz şunu görüyoruz
ve bu fırsatlar sürekli değişiyorsa Ne o
zaman en önemli şey girişimciliğin
kuralları da sürekli değişiyor ve
güncelleniyor o zaman da bizim bu
başarılı kurucularda gördüğümüz en
önemli özellik ve olmazsa olmaz Hatta
yegane özellik sizin de Sürekli
öğrenebilen kendi kendine öğrenebilen ve
sürekli değişken bir yapımız olması
gerekiyor ve bunun da en önemli özellik
olduğunu görüyoruz Biz Çünkü Mesela
bugün bir Facebook'a baktığınız zaman
15-20 sene önceki Facebook'la şu anki
Facebook arasında dağlar kadar fark var
apple'a baktığınızda aynı şekilde
Google'a baktığınızda aynı şekilde ama
bunların yaptığı şey ne her zaman o
andaki zamanın fırsatlarını görüp
sürekli sürekli sürekli kendilerini
yeniliyorlar yeni ürünler yeni
özellikler çıkarabiliyorlar
girişimcilerin de teknoloji
girişimcilerinde en önemli özelliğinin
genelde bu olduğunu görüyoruz ve ben
buna çok sevdiğim bir şiirle de bitirmek
istiyorum
Yani kendini keşfet kendimi Yenile sonra
kendini tekrar Yenile asla aynı yerde
yüzme ve ondan sonra tekrar kendini
Yenile Ondan sonra tekrar kendine Yenile
ve o kadar kendini Yenile ki şeklin
konuşma tarzını o kadar değişsin ki yani
seni hiçbir şekilde kategoriye
koyamasınlar ve hatta daha sonra da
kendi bir konuşmasında diye
tanıyamasınlar bile ve gerçekten de
girişimcilere baktığınız zaman bugün bir
başarılı bir girişimciye gidin 10 sene
önceki haliyle şu anki aile arasında da
gerçekten dağlar kadar fark oluyor ve
Yani buradan tek çıkartmanız gereken en
önemli şey
Sürekli kendi kendine öğrenebilen bir
insan olup fırsatları görebildiğiniz
takdirde milyar dolarlık şirket kurma
şansınız artıyor başka açıkçası pek bir
şeye ihtiyacınız yok değil bitiriyorum
Çok teşekkür ederim
davet ettiğiniz için